hello everyone i hope you're doing good
and staying safe welcome to another
interesting tutorial on sql joins by
simply learn in today's session we'll
learn what exactly is sql join and its
various types as the name suggests join
means to combine something in a similar
way sql join is used to combine records
from two or more tables in a database
more on that soon but before we get
started if you are tech geek and the
pursuit of learning new technologies
consider getting subscribed to our
channel simply learn to stay updated
with all the latest tech content and hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from us so without any further delay
let's get started with today's topic
firstly let us discuss the agenda for
today's session we'll start the tutorial
by understanding what is sql join and
then we'll discuss why we use sql join
and then we'll go through different
types of sql joins such as sql inner
join sql outer join sqlf join and
finally sql right join
so without any further delay let us dive
straight into today's topic so what is
sql join in relational databases the
information you want to retrieve is
often stored in various different tables
in such scenarios you'll need to join
these tables to view data in a much
better way this is where sql join comes
into picture sql joins is widely used
clause in s in sql essentially to
combine and retrieve data from two or
more tables
based on related columns or you can say
common fields between them now consider
two tables here table one has three
columns abc and three records let's say
for reference we'll take them as one two
three similarly table two also has three
columns bcd and three records three four
five here i have taken a different color
combination to represent values that are
present in various columns now instead
of querying each table every time to
retrieve data i'll simply join these two
tables and this will be the following
resultant table
also make sure when you're joining two
tables it should compulsorily have a
common column here c is the common field
which forms the basis to join these two
tables here
why we use sql join
flexibility sql join allows the user to
access and manage records from more than
one table easily
let us understand with an example
consider mercedes-benz which is one of
the leading car manufacturers in the
world and let's say they want to access
the records of the customers from the
database now in the database let us take
they have various different kinds of
tables such as customer table order
table vehicle table now if they want to
get the vehicle details of so and so
customer xyz for that they have to first
query the cursor table to get the
customer id now if once if they get the
customer id they have to query the order
table to get the order id and finally
with the help of order id they can get
the vehicle details now as you can see
this is a time taking process and hectic
at the same time now instead of that
i'll just simply join these tables
which will allow the users to combine
rows from two or more tables based on
different types of conditions in this
way you can access and manage your
records easily
data redundancy sql join allows
the user to maintain data redundancy as
much as low as possible so that we can
maintain the amount of data anomalies
that is the duplicate values that are
repeated in various tables in the
database
finally efficiency sql join executes the
query faster and shows the result much
more quickly because instead of using
various sub queries for each and every
table individually we can just simply
join uh two tables using a
simple single query
types of sql joins sql joins are broadly
classified into four types they are
inner join outer join left join right
join and additionally we also have cross
join which is not that significant uh in
its usage because most of the times we
use the first four joints
now that we have gone through different
types of sql joins let us discuss each
of them in detail
firstly let us discuss about sql inner
join sql inner join joins two tables
based on a common column and selects the
records that have matching values in
these columns
now when the condition
is applied for these columns the query
checks all the rows of table 1 and table
2. only the rows that satisfy the join
predicate are included in the resultant
table
let us now understand the uh syntax of
the sql inner join the syntax is
followed as select table one dot column
one table one dot column two table do
dot column one and so on from table one
inner join table two on table one dot
column equals to table two dot column
now inner join syntax basically compares
rows of table one with table two to
check if any anything matches based on
the condition provided in the on clause
and when the condition is met it returns
matched rows in both tables with the
selected columns in the select clause
let us now discuss about the sql outer
join sql outer join or else it is called
as sql full join or full outer join is
used to get all the rows which are
present in both the tables that means it
will return all the records which are
present in either left table that is the
table 1 or the right table that is table
2 even if there are no matching records
present in both the tables let us now
understand the syntax the syntax remains
same that is select table 1 dot column 1
table one dot column two and so on up to
table two dot column two from table one
full outer join is the keyword that we
use here table two on table one dot
column equals to table two dot column
now here you have to mention the uh the
same or the similar column name in the
after the on predicate statement
next we have sql left join
left join or left outer join also known
as left join results in a table
containing all the rows from the table
on the left side of the join that is the
first table and only the rows that
satisfy the join condition from the
table on the right side of the join that
is the second table any missing values
for the rows from the right table in the
result of the join tables are
represented by null values let's look at
the syntax the syntax is followed as
select column list that is the column
that you want to uh display in your
table now make sure you maintain the uh
syntax of the column list that is the
table name dot column name otherwise it
will throw an error so let me just
repeat the syntax the syntax is select
column list from table one the keyword
that we use here is left join table two
on table one dot column equals to table
two dot column
so in this way you can use the left join
to display the records
next finally we have the uh sql right
join now
right join or right outer join is
opposite to that of the left outer join
now it follows the same rules as the
left join and the only difference is
that all the rows from the right table
and only the conditions satisfying the
rows from the left table are present in
the resultant table that means it will
return all the rows from the right table
and all the matching records that are
present in the left table the syntax
remains the same that is select column
list that you want to display in your
table from table 1 write join is the
keyword we use table 2 on table 1 dot
column equals to table two dot column
now to sum up all these different sql
joins and how they work i've taken a
graphical representation of two
different tables here which will help us
visualize the real time working of sql
joins now consider table one here which
is columns a and b and records uh two
different records let's say record zero
record one and similarly we have table
two which have uh columns a and c and
two records that is record zero and
record two now if you apply left join
and by the definition of left join it
will only uh return those values which
will which are present in the left table
and the matching records that are
present in the right table now here the
uh
matching value that are present in both
the tables is zero and they require
values that are present in the left
table is one and if you consider the
right join it will match the request
from both the tables and it will display
the only the values from the right table
that is the reason it is being displayed
uh the record zero and the record two
and if you look at the inner join it
will match
uh the values from both the tables now
the common value that is present in both
the tables is record 0
and if you finally look at the outer
join it will record it will return all
the values from both the tables
irrespective if they are matching or not
that is the reason
all the records that is record 0 record
1 and record 2 are being displayed
and with that we have come to the end of
today's session that was all about sql
joins stay tuned for more upcoming
videos veren will execute all these
types of joints in mysql workbench using
various examples thank you for watching
the video guys i hope you found this
tutorial useful and informative if you
have any further queries regarding any
of the topics covered in the uh tutorial
feel free to let us know in the comment
section below and a team of experts will
be more than happy to resolve all your
queries at the earliest until next time
stay safe and keep coding
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here